inundaciones ríos desbordados y ya está
desaparecidos este es el panorama en el
occidente y el centro de cuba tras más
de 28 horas de lluvias ininterrumpidas
provocadas por la tormenta tropical álex
alta intensidad ha sido mucha mucha la
intensidad de la lluvia no entra gante
que aguantes no se puede por la lluvia
pasado y se había apagado la guardia a
la cintura
y
vivir como remo viviendo con el agua por
las rodillas los cubanos han estado
intentando empujar autos y autobuses
atascados en las calles de la capital la
habana después de que el fenómeno
acumularse hasta 300 mililitros de agua
por metro cuadrado en algunas zonas
varias regiones del país están
incomunicadas y cientos de personas han
tenido que ser evacuadas por la
televisión
con el gobierno de miguel díaz canel
ella avisó que toda la isla está en
alerta máxima hasta próximo aviso por la
tormenta alex formada por los restos del
huracán agatha que había pasado en los
días anteriores por méxico dejando
muertos y desaparecidos desde el centro
nacional de huracanes de estados unidos
se espera que las lluvias continúen en
la isla a esta entrada a la noche de
este viernes y se espera que sigan
después en florida y las islas bahamas